first of all
congratulations on the emmy win last
night best drama series
we're uh
we're so proud of that because it means
that every single person who works on
the show both in in albuquerque and here
in los angeles and the folks in new york
the studio the network everybody has a
piece of that victory and that's that's
what we're really happy about also it
was clear to me when i went backstage to
say hi that you guys have been partying
hard
for 24 hours
he just got in yeah he is now rolled in
from all the parties right he has no
idea who i am right now
yo [ __ ] yo [ __ ]
[Applause]
we have so much ground to cover so much
to talk about aaron what i love is that
idiots like me and everyone in the press
has been asking you guys for months
what's going to happen what's going to
happen what's going to happen your stock
answer is everyone dies
that's what you've been saying explain
that because
just just tell me how it ends just who
dies does walt die does jessie die do
they kill each other and then finally
she's like listen everyone
just everyone dies
she's an easy easy way out does that
bother people when you tell them that
yes
the only one is true though yeah yeah
it's true for every occasion yeah the
only one who stays alive is holly
and so we have a sequel you know holly
white
the story continues
the year she has a little gun
baby heisenberg
ah baby heisenberg
now brian one of the revelations of this
show for you as an actor is that you're
such a
a nice guy
you're such a sweet presence you're so
amiable but man you have a scary face
when you want to have a scary when you
want to have a scary face i don't know
how you do it well i
it's funny you should mention that
because i always thought that even no
emotion whatsoever i have a scary face
period
so if for instance okay if i'm looking
at this camera no emotion whatsoever the
the the thing that you read is fear
that's fantastic
it's terrifying yeah is that work for
everybody it works for well let's but
what is what is the one word that you
sense when you look in no emotion
whatsoever
completely devoid
[Applause]
um i see it's a bit of sadness
i'm just it feels like i'm not getting
enough oxygen
it just makes sense
it's like you wet yourself
[Laughter]
yeah what am i looking at well the one
with the red light no emotion at all
none whatsoever
feel it
you look angry he looks like an angry
principal you're goddamn right
now aaron where am i looking okay aaron
where are you
nothing no emotion
you're a moanings i'm not trying do
anything
wipe it all away
[Laughter]
oh that's sweet look at it
[Applause]
i got a guy
i was getting a guy thinking about lunch
that's what i was getting
i'm really
you've had
your fans are absolutely uh incredible
they are so loyal uh brian you see that
you got one fan letter that really stood
out
of all the fan letters i was i we were
talking about that i said i'm gonna
bring this fan letter with me can i read
it too yes you may all right so this f
this is an honest goodness fan letter
came to me it says dear brian cranston
let me preface this letter by saying i
have a master's degree in psychology and
i have never been diagnosed with any
psychotic disorder
you know when a when a letter starts out
with
i have never been diagnosed with any
psychotics
no one's caught me yet
[Laughter]
i am writing to you because i have been
holed up in my apartment for two days
and nights watching all seasons of your
show i am in love with it all after i
was done with all the episodes i watched
some interviews and what this is all
amounted to is that right now i am
fantasizing about having sex
with aaron paul
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and
and
for you to be there watching
swear to god it's a true yeah what are
you doing in this scenario it says i am
not sure what your role would be
but i think i want you there
i think he's giving you some leeway yeah
it's up to you you'll figure it out you
say he's giving me some leeway yeah is
it he or she it's a shame oh i thought
it was a he the whole time
[Applause]
you you picture the letter however you
want i'll picture it how i want it
the last thing she
says is come on it would be a good time
fine let me have sex with aaron and you
watch come on trust me
now i have to bring this up there are so
many finale theories there's actually a
theory
for the finale that walt's in the
witness protection program he gets a new
family
and he changes his name to howe and it's
the prequel to malcolm in the middle
that was a that was
which i thought was a genius that's
ingenious that's ingenious that's and
then that whole series runs and that
series runs but it it already ran so how
do we don't you understand man yeah
time doesn't mean anything man
speaking of the last episode i none of
us
we don't want to know anything but it
but what i do
have what i heard about two hours ago
was that you
read the two of you read the last
episode together yes before you shot it
you sat together and you read it is that
right yes we there's a there's a really
wonderful documentary that uh two-hour
documentary that's going to be in the
final um compilation of uh dvds and uh
it's really in-depth and uh we we
thought it would be a fun idea for aaron
and i to read it cold
out loud uh in this documentary so we
read this without knowing what was going
to happen and then they intercut that
earlier with with
vince gilligan writing the last episode
it was a it was a fun thing and was that
must have been very powerful when you
got towards the end it was a
very
emotional experience i think i mean for
for us for sure i mean
when he said uh when he read out loud
end of series there was probably a good
10 15 seconds we were just just sitting
quietly going
wow we're never going to read another
first episode again it's over yeah
thanks for bringing that up
i can't think of a better time to go to
commercial on that
on that huge laugh we'll be right back